NATIONAL HOCKEY LEAGUE SEASON.
I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO SEEING
WHAT HAPPENS HERE.
>> David: WE HAVE A TRADE
SITUATION TO HEAR ABOUT ON THE
FLOOR.
>> YOU'RE LOSING SOME ENERGY BUT
I HAVE TWO TRADES TO --
[ Cheering ]
-- THAT'S GOOD!
YOU WANT TO HEAR THE TWO TRADES?
THEY INVOLVE THE CANADIENS!
[ Cheering ]
TRADE NUMBER ONE, MONTREAL
CANADIENS TRADE ALEXANDER
ROMANOV AND PICK NUMBER 98 IN
THIS YEAR'S DRAFT TO THE NEW
YORK ISLANDERS IN EXCHANGE FOR
PICK NUMBER 13 IN THIS YEAR'S
DRAFT!
>> OH!
>> STARTING TO BE A FAN
FAVOURITE HERE.
>> NUMBER TWO, MONTREAL TRADES
PICKS NUMBER 13 AND 66 IN THIS
YEAR'S DRAFT TO THE CHICAGO
BLACKHAWKS IN EXCHANGE FOR KIRBY
DICH.
[ Cheering ]
AND WITH THAT THE FOURTH
SELECTION IN THE 2022 NHL DRAFT